okey-dokey let's see how we look hope
everyone's doing okay yes it is angle
sucks though again always does uh that's
that'll do
cool hope everybody's doing okay
how's tricks I was it wasn't feeling
great
earlier today I'm doing all right now
happy world Pride Day thank you thank
you very much so you'll notice that
there's no real specific topic for this
one I haven't listened is just Q and a
live stream because I don't have any
specific things that are on top of mine
to address right now so this is gonna be
a little bit more of a free-for-all now
fair warning that does mean if I get a
hammered with questions if you want your
stuff prioritize I'm gonna recommend the
super chat otherwise that will catch
them on as best as I can
evening waiting to hear from you casting
12 Angry Men oh that's a fun show I've
been in that one I was juror seven for
that hey there Ian water again I guess
it's from account yeah yeah it's not the
cleanest water in the world but what's
your favorite movie ghostbusters Return
to Oz turns 3520 first what are your
thoughts I haven't watched it since I
was in my early teens so I don't really
have any finally got the tans temporal
sonic screwdriver I also ordered to buy
a gender-fluid flag moving up the world
ooh it's all kinds of swag nicely done
looking to your time I'm looking forward
to your time with the doctor review
tomorrow heaven rewashing years I just
remember it being boring
I think it was the narrations yeah
that's uh that is an odd duck of an
episode it was interesting to go back
and re-watch it which Ghostbusters do
you love the shirt yes thank you this I
actually got a number of things in from
from a friend of mine hi-ho silver
designed this they have a lot of great
stuff up on their site I don't think I
have it in the description yet well this
gets archived I'll put a link to their
their online store in the in the
description biggest prediction for
revolutions that I don't have
predictions seriously people don't ask
you for predictions I don't do that
how's your daughter doing she's doing
okay it's it's gonna be a weird summer
we had this may be a controversial
opinion but the Speed Racer movies
fantastic flip and awesome seriously I
recommend it highly
never seen it thoughts on the rumors
that the new Star Wars trilogy will be
strike from Canon the franchise will be
overseen by Favreau going forward it's a
rumor I have no thoughts that's long
standing until something's official I
don't have an opinion first time live
here but been chatting up on all the big
catching up on all the great videos you
made thank you Steve finally finished
Buffy Season 1 really mixed bag also
notice that episode that is similar to
your favorite Real Ghostbusters episode
yeah they do have one that's not a
million miles away do you know Derek
Jacobi he played the master before
utopia and an animation called scream of
the shaaka
I did know that I've seen it I do need
to re-watch it and like eventually do a
video on it
what are your thoughts on Basil the
Great Mouse Detective my favorite Disney
film I'm rather fond of that and
Ratigan's one of my favorite Disney
villains very important question what do
you use on McDonald's chicken selects is
there a view to be had is that like
there's sandwiches or is that something
they've got I don't even know what your
and out of curiosity when it comes to
Whitaker era will they be included in
your doctor who Reve review given how
long it's gonna take me to get their
series 11 probably series 12 that's a
bit more of an open question thoughts on
the latest TMNT reboot I didn't even
keep up with the last reboot or the one
before that they reboot that franchise
so freaking often I can't can I can I
keep up rumor has it that margot robbie
will star in the next Pirates of the
Caribbean reboot again rumor if it's not
official I don't really have an opinion
question that's been bugging me for
years
who do I argue with if I think the last
Jedi was just okay well that means you
can argue with everybody cuz that's
basically where I like look I have a lot
more annoyances to say about the thing
that others but I don't think it's a bad
movie and I've gotten into plenty of
arguments with people who make
criticisms of it that I think are
nonsense
so that just means you argue with
everyone remember the awesome milkshakes
milkshakes that Zach species used to
have I don't know if that's a reference
to something that I'm missing I would
feel bad if I feel like someone's
dropping an in Jogja that just went over
my head
red flags with masterful and big finish
they released the poster and Delgado and
Amy are shown on I think they made me
recasting yeah they already confirmed
that that they they're having
sound-alikes which it's not something
that I love that happens you're trapped
on a desert island what do you take well
a teleporter and get off the damn Island
I cook for those kinds of questions
ah do you like hitchhikers guide and if
somebody a favor of medium to view it I
love hitchhikers guide and my preferred
way to take it in is the audiobook
version of the novels as read by Douglas
Adams should Buffy have chosen angel
Riley or spike
none of the above cuz she was young and
in a lot of really lousy toxic
relationships she needs to be single for
a while get good with herself five
Doctor Who stories included being
Finnish if you were stuck on a desert
island I've made predictions to your
answers no I'm not building a psych
psychological profile um
city of death Holy Terror silence in the
library that two-parter that's that
that's three so far um haven't sent
Vincent and the doctor kiss marry kill
all the new who doctors that doesn't
work kiss marry killers requires three
people what we're on our what our fourth
now but fine if you count John Hurt no
that doesn't work
worst casting choice in the hit in the
2005 hitchhikers movie so I know mm-hmm
I
his name is all of a sudden slipping my
mind I don't know why I know his name
cuz I got a complain about him Sam
Rockwell Jesus yeah I I hate that zaphod
so much and I know he's not even the
character who gets butchered the worst
from a from a strict in terms of how
badly did they botch this perspective
but zip was my favorite character in
those books and it missed the key reason
as to why
I love him as a character because the
thing that's great about Zaphod in the
books is that he acts like an idiot not
because he's stupid but for any litany
of reasons including acting like an
idiot is more advantageous under the
circumstances covering up the fact that
he doesn't actually know what's going on
but wants to keep people off their guard
or he knows that there's people around
him that will do the thinking for him so
he doesn't have to when the chips are
down if he has to work it out he can
he's actually really smart he's just
lazy and the movie just made him a
straight-up idiot ah God that ticked me
off
is it wrong to blame the showrunner if
doctor who's a show lessons in quality
as we don't know what the BBC demands of
them and what their is a corporation
warm for the show um I mean is it right
probably not but since we don't know all
the internal mechanisms at the BBC
that's about as high as we can go with
criticisms you know and let unless
somebody does a tell-all book that's
kind of all we got it's fun to remember
that sarah michelle gellar was in i know
what you did last summer and Buffy at
the same time that went on to be in
scream - yeah she was busy when was some
cruel intentions in there somewhere -
would it be a bigger challenge to watch
all Doctor Who TV episodes or listen to
all the Big Finish it'd be a heck of a
lot more expensive to listen to all the
Big Finish
so if money is no option I don't know
Big Finish still probably cuz there's
actually probably more hours of Big
Finish than that then classic who what
doctors would you like to see returned
for the 60th what ones will actually do
it um I would really love to see
Eccleston back I don't know if I don't
know if he'll do it like as many as they
can get to be honest um yeah we just
grabbed Sylvester McCoy grab Peter
Davison grab everybody you've got while
they're still here
I mean if Tom Baker doesn't feel up to
it we got him in the fiftieth okay fine
if you could add a regeneration as a
concept to any other piece of fiction
with no need to explain it what would
you pick ooh that is an interesting
question um see the thing is I was going
to think of something like from comics
to accept comics just to reboot their
continuity of the dang time which is
effectively the same dang thing um
that's a really good question I wish I
had a good answer for it ah dang it
I don't know like any anything that that
is meant to be an ongoing franchise you
could add that to and have a nice you
know chance to revamp and keep it and
keep it going kind of thing but I I'm I
mean James Bond feels like the obvious
answer but I'm drawing a blank at a
better suggestion what I meant was that
each new Doctor Who that we've seen gets
the title kiss marry or kill oh I'm
still gonna respectively pass because I
hate the premise of that game can I be
completely honest like I I don't I just
don't like it I think it I think it's
the terminology I don't like and you
seen Scott Pilgrim vs. the world I have
I have a rewatched it a long time but my
opinion of it as time has been going on
has been dropping like don't get me
wrong it's phenomenally well presented
it's a really well-made film it's
visually invented but there are things
about that movie that I'm just
and they should not have ended up
together
at the end of that movie these are two
damaged people that need to not be in a
relationship right now I got three right
city of death holy terror intent and
Heaven Sent I thought you'd say midnight
and empty child / the doctor dances ah
did you ever watch Twin Peaks nope I
David Lynch is he I cannot tune into
that guy's wavelength worse start to who
showrunner including the classic error
problem is I don't know the the classic
era of showrunners like who was running
what segments well enough off the top of
my head so I'm actually gonna pass on
that and now agree with you that the
bastion of Narada should not come back
but I'm gonna try and write a
hypothetical script what they do was a
writing challenge if you want to give
yourself range it's fine
any thoughts on the expanse never seen
it never read it don't know anything
about it I know that it exists have you
read deceased comic books if not it's
basically DC response to the Marvel
Zombies oh god I hate Marvel Zombies oh
no I haven't read it it kind of grosses
me out that it exists hey how would you
feel about the Rani returning to hmm
huh how would you feel about the Iranian
returning to Doctor Who I think it will
work because the only other Time Lord
uses a main villains master and it is
getting old I don't like the Rani I've
never liked the Rani I like some of the
core concepts of the Rani but they were
done badly at this point basically the
entire time Lord cast of Gallifrey uns
are effectively villains at this point
we don't need more singled out Time Lord
villains I have no interest in the Rani
none if they get as many doctors as
possible for the 60th do you think it
will be hard to do each doctor justice
in one Episode two part of perhaps it
depends what you have them do so like
for instance the way they use Tom Baker
in the 50th he's in one scene a couple
of minutes but it's brilliant and it's
perfect if you try to have them all in
on the adventure from the start yeah
that's gonna be impossible to balance
but if you can find ways to have them
touch base have them little moments to
themselves that gets to be their moment
I think that could work
do you enjoy preferred ship knows
treatment of the Daleks compared to
Moffat yes I don't feel like I can pin
down chip Niles approach beyond
reserving them for the specials which I
am in favor of but like what is that
okay
there we go I don't know what happened I
kind of wish that Missy didn't
regenerate yet just because I would love
to see Michelle Gomez and Jodie
Whittaker play off each other yeah I
wish me make sure I'll go miss it suck
around to what extra alien treat or
characteristics do you think would
enhance the doctors character I'm not
actually sure how to parse that question
he doesn't the doctor doesn't need more
alien traits they're just the doctor I
I feel like you just don't understand
what you're asking should cereal be
eaten throughout the day or is it just
for breakfast cereals great for snacks
no no shame in that
regeneration would break any needlessly
bloody series like Game of Thrones would
have had characters you actually have to
talk to each other and be way more fun
slash less shocking well see I I don't
feel prepared to judge it because they
never read the books I've heard much
better things about the books in the
show especially now
excuse me thought the show's wrapped up
did you see baby driver yes got it in
just on the wire under the wire catching
that in the theater not too long before
the Kevin Spacey allegations broke so
yeah man that was fun
it's a pretty good movie though I'm
again I'm not in love with it
anchor right is a very good filmmaker I
don't always love his movies but I do
enjoy them at least once
have you watched dark nope uh haven't
heard the allegations about Ansel Elgort
yeah I heard about that too speaking
baby driver it's really gonna fix field
Berg's West Side Story yeah quite
possibly if you could learn a fictional
language what would you choose I feel
like Klingons the most fun sounding
would you like to who would you like to
see is the doctor or the master I'm
skipping that question I did a whole
video on viable doctors but like dream
casting is not really my headspace if
Harry Potter was remained she to be a
series with one book per season or his
movies again okay so setting aside my
current feelings on not wanting to put
any money towards Harry Potter anymore
aside for the moment treating them
strictly astera Tibbs if they weren't
gonna adopt them again they should do it
differently and doing them as a series
with each book being a year which would
allow them much more
time to spend time in the classrooms and
that's a very easy way to expand and get
the the full runtime that you need
without having to invent a whole bunch
of plaque whole cloth you just come up
with more more classroom stuff in
between to pad the runtime so it's very
feasible I think could work very well as
a series I don't think I'd watch it but
you know that's uh that's a whole other
thing
just just saw your Harley Quinn review I
just love how if dr. psycho that said
the C world
Z word in Britain C world mm C word in
Britain people wouldn't care in the
slightest it is funny to me that that
that word is a swear is way more
acceptable in the UK ever watched
Justice League dark apocalypse war I
have not yet I'm afraid to I've really
hated the DC animated films based on the
new 52
just saw last week's tonight episode on
Oh a n has left me mesmerized by the
sentence
don't let transgender penguins fool you
yeah I saw that that was those a month
or two ago they covered that nonsense
ultimate pitch the doctor meets the
Justice League
do you watch jellies marble runs and if
you don't please do I don't sounds like
something my daughter would watch
finally finished last season of Angel
wasn't disappointed but I wasn't blown
away I'm sorry you weren't cuz I
actually I still argue that angel is one
of the best series finales in television
did you know that
Helen McRoy was originally going to play
Bellatrix but then she became pregnant
so the role went to Helena Bonham Carter
I think you did hear that at some point
but it's not something that has really
stuck in my head
what do you think about the idea that
the TARDIS translates the story for the
audience I've never heard that I'm not
even entirely sure how that would
functionally be different from it
translating for the say to the
companions and just as it campaigns
usually the POV anyways I okay theory
what oh boy theories and I don't mean I
don't mean to be grumpy and dismissive
but like I I've got videos on this
channel about why I go do I am bad for
fan theory what if the Time Lords and
gala friends are just evolved humans no
no no
do you like doctor who's been off plat
that's a team but why would he look but
why do you look so much like recently
canceled daily blogger V or a while what
was what happened to me with that is
that consider being cancelled
now having one large youtuber decide to
make fun of me you know one of my
friends saying is you're either a good
seat worker Pat's Heuer haha I like that
and no I've said it before and I'll say
it again ultimate crossover is Buffy and
Torchwood see that I could buy I that
I'd be up for only finished season one
of angels still got more to go season
one of angels rough it gets much better
after that the 1989 TV adaptation of The
Woman in Black is finally getting a
blu-ray release the lead is Adrian
Rollins please Daniel Radcliffe dad and
you know what see I saw the movie
version of Ullman and glutton black that
has Daniel Radcliffe in it and it's
really good I love your rant on bard
core thank you I'm glad you enjoyed that
why the euphemism are you not talking
about Avatar The Last Airbender cuz I
haven't seen it God people there's a
comic book that has an interesting
premise for the weeping angels they
offer soldiers in World War one and
escape back in time it's quite gruesome
one soldier staples his eyes open yikes
world war one would be a good setting
for the Angels
that's that solid thinking there
I'm sorry I made you drink have a
chicken I a commie chicken nugget no
thank you so much there's apparently
once a couple who decided to raise their
kid with Klingon it worked great until
they had to go to school and learn
English and said yeah that's exactly
what would happen well on apocalypse
ward senator on konstantin act of the jl
lost darkside also its r-rated don't
care
so some unnecessary cursing to make the
movie be more edgy and gory I really
hate that I've come to really really
resent things that seem to be r-rated
for no reason other than swearing and a
violence level that is not necessitated
by the narrative or the characters of
the story at all it's just like look at
us we're so edgy no you're not you're
sophomoric you're juvenile
that's not mature you'll McGregor was my
favorite part of birds of prey and again
I am disappointed by them killing off
the villain at the end of the film
instead of continuing the story into the
future I here's the thing I would agree
with you if I felt that the DC movies
had any plan firmly in place there's no
plan at this point and knowing that
there's no plan I don't think there's a
need to save villains for later use the
way that I would the way that I be
annoyed is something like say the Marvel
movies where there would be a reason for
them to come back and be reused what are
your thoughts on Helen McCrory as
rosanna calvierri and vampires of Venice
and Narcissa Malfoy she's fine
none of those are neither of those are
particularly memorable roles for me you
clearly be Helen McCrory Finn that's
great sorry I'm not I don't have a
problem you students sticking my head
please do an audio book or ASMR I love
your voice I
really do need to try and find the time
to record an audio book version of
skirting gender that is I might to do
list that and editing the friggin novel
I've got so many plates spinning it's
ridiculous what angel really changes is
the crazy go necks been in the body of
it it starts changing can't wait for
masterful though one of the big reasons
is the Eric Roberts master is actually
good and Big Finish well I mean he
couldn't be much worse that that would
have been a trip that no terrified me
apparently all humanoid life-forms are
based on timeless because of Rassilon
meddling with starting the universe is
that better or worse that is the same
kind of bad that is neither better nor
worse stop tying everything together I
mean this for fans for writers you
continuity hounds stop making everything
connected when it creates a story to
connect things okay but to connect it
just to connect it it doesn't make the
world bigger it makes the world smaller
the world the universe fiction or
otherwise is big enough that things just
happened things are random not
everything is related to something else
I know some continuity hounds really
love to make everything connected I hate
that hmm
umbrella Academy it's fine
I didn't love the ending because I don't
love where they took that it's been so
long since I've seen it now but the the
the person who turned out to be the
villain in love where they took that
character story we heard the drama
between Jeffrey and Shane I don't even
know who you're referring
- and I strongly suspect that if you
told me I would not care I'm grumpy
tonight I'm just gonna I'm gonna
apologize right now I can feel it in my
bones that I'm grumpy uh I am sorry I
got legitimately sorry that I was so
grouchy tonight the board of the TARDIS
translating for the audience is that the
different tones or because the audience
expectation changes that any pop culture
is just for us not strictly Canon well
that's kind of a fun way to remove the
pop culture references except that the
pop culture references pretty much only
ever come from characters who would know
them be they the doctor or or you know
somebody from Earth or what-have-you so
I'm not sure you need that as a way to
explain it away I mean if you person
feel the need to explain it away that's
a neat headcanon reason for it sure I've
seen the last airbender several people
typing like I feel like everyone should
know that buckle that I haven't seen
that yet
are rated for no reason me hides my copy
of the Torchwood sex gas episode oh I
hate that episode of almost made me quit
that show that's how much I hated that
uh I have a question for you do you
think about do you think about what if
doctor who ever had to cross over with
clive barker's characters like 9 3 2 the
santa bites no I've never thought about
that
um although the doctor encountering
something like the Senna bites I'd
actually be kind of curious about I feel
like that would have to be a like a
companion free story but um yeah I'd be
curious of that it's cursing still
juvenile if it's part of your culture I
don't know depends on the culture like
here's the thing when I say cursey is
juvenile I don't necessarily mean in in
your personal interactions or your life
I mean in pieces of entered
tainment so like if the way you talk
with your friends or whatever is just to
swear a lot to spine but yeah I was
talking I was talking about movies
trying to keep up with these questions
but I'm losing it
are you excited for the Batman not
really I really need a neater trailer
what do you think of the quiz' turns in
Star Wars Jedi fallen order I haven't
played it Big Finish actually did create
one of the best crossovers we needed but
never asked for a Captain Jack and
Jackie Tyler oh dear
oh my have you read Doctor Who Star Trek
stories simulation and what is your
opinion of it I don't have them because
they haven't read it why do I feel like
you'd look good in cloud glasses if you
don't know what they're look up cloud
sunglasses I'm gonna have to look that
up because I have no idea what that is
okay now that now that's bugging me um
oh I've actually got a pair kind of in
that style they're not white duh most of
these are white they're like um the pink
I don't wear them cuz they're not
prescription cuz I got a blank for uh I
think for a photo shoot ages ago here's
something to expand around the works for
those continuity hounds the doctors
half-human on his mother's side I said
in the TV movie yes but we ignore that
cuz it was stupid see that that's my
opinion to continuity if something is
stupid or doesn't make sense just ignore
it you don't have to explain it you
don't have to wreak on in just don't
talk about it that is a much better
solution in my mind
have you seen broadchurch I saw the
first series I've actually got reviews
up on the channel from a couple years
ago I didn't feel the need to keep going
it was good though he wouldn't've a get
scared gets his deep
voice I don't think you know that but I
I i do get growly when i get really
annoyed um do you like colorized older
films or is the vandalism I don't think
it's vandalism but I think it's
completely unnecessary and pointless I
don't know why anyone would do that
I mean like you could make the argument
that they would have shot in color if
they could have yes but they didn't and
they shot for what they had they shot
for it to be viewed in black and white
yeah no I got him get that I will never
understand colorization ferric Roberts
was any worse than Big Finish it would
have Lou back if we become Tommy Wiseau
levels of brilliant
FairPoint that was one of the big
prospect to the unnecessary linking of
Daniel Craig era films yes holy crap
yeah all of that movie pissed me off so
much
there has to be continuity for
everything laughs in 57 year old show
yeah see that here's my opinion in a
continuity in general I love continuity
nods I love acknowledgments of the
continuity I like plucking a piece out
of it like doing something new with it
or going or even just a name drop
I love acknowledgments of continuity
what I hate is getting tied up in the
continuity because if you take
continuity too seriously it actually
really limits what you're able to do
because you're all you're tied knots
trying to make continuity work and I
think that that's that's a waste of
effort and talent this has to be the
TARDIS no need to build connecting
bridges to go between places and times
yes you'd think which modern who
companion is least likely to return at
this point I'd probably say Donna which
saddens me but I'm gonna stick to that
just because they'd have to
they'd have to explain why her head
doesn't explode and I guess they did
that once before but like that's the
thing about Donna like you can't bring
her back and have it be the same again
even with even accounting for the fact
that it's a new doctor because she's not
supposed to remember would you ever
consider doing over the overdue reviews
of Torchwood that is sort of on the list
of things where I think somebody would
have to pay me I mean that that's how
you folks got the review of children of
Earth somebody actually commissioned
that I don't think I like Torchwood
enough to sync the time into it of my
own accord
I think it's excuse me I think somebody
would have to Commission me
things that try to be edgy even worse
when they are poor imitations of great
works that happen to be dark and assumes
you'll like them just because they were
I mean well that was the entire kickoff
to the Dark Age of comic books right
because it was largely kicked off by the
Dark Knight Returns and Watchmen both of
which are really good stories that
happen to be dark but they're not good
because they're dark but a million
friggin imitators came in after that
thinking oh well we just need to do dark
comics hmm then we got the 90s oh god
the 90s oh hey Ava didn't see you there
my head Canon Amy big beam to the center
back in time where it centroid angel
touched her by and touched by her
voluntary sacrifice for the power of
love weeps for really grants her request
oh I like that Amy Rory laid back in New
York in 1970 in an alleyway just as a
young girl finishes her regeneration
back into a toddler that would have been
the twist and PS oh I like that too yeah
it's definitely my head Canon it's like
doctor says Arthur Dent he means a
person who travels the universe and a
dressing-gown not The Hitchhiker's Guide
not that Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy Doctor Who are connected well
I've actually talked about that that's
like that so I don't ever want that
confirmed but she kind of liked the idea
that they might be what must we do to
get you watch Avatar The Last Airbender
create more time see unlike say
Torchwood I don't feel like I need
somebody to pay me to get to avatar I'll
get to it eventually but the problem is
I have I've got all this other stuff
that I have been paid to watch a review
that I'm trying to catch up on and so
you know I I I'm sure I will like it
when I eventually get to it if you want
to bump it up my priority list yeah
somebody could Commission me you can't
be grumpy you don't have the eyebrows
for it oh look I may not have Capaldi
level attack eyebrows
but I can wield these all right
ah I'm calling it Jennifer Hudson is
winning Best Actress for a respect it's
gonna be in a lot of ward season just
cuz it's gonna be so few options
I always interpret the doctor being half
human as metaphorical um well if you
watched that TV movie no they they make
it very literal they make it a plot
point cuz it's why the master can't open
the eye of Harmony cuz he's all Time
Lord whereas the doctors half human so
it's not just the tossed off line that
the doctor has they actually made it a
plot point in that thing
imagine if Captain Jack met the Sixth
Doctor Nobel brows strong jaws all
around so if you could choose who would
be the fourteenth doctor honestly I just
give it to Joe Martin list of things to
annoy he are a timeless child Clara half
human dr. sex yes
Torchwood episode Time Lords are evolved
humans Oh
God you people are keeping track of ways
to annoy me I'm giving you so much
ammunition I think Benedict Cumberbatch
will be an awesome doctor mm-hmm look I
like Benedict Cumberbatch but like he's
gotten embedded in too many things that
I like at this point you know he's in
Marvel he's Sherlock he was in the Lord
Rings movie I mean you know the bad
Hobbit was but like he's just he's into
many things I don't need him in
everything I mean I'm starting to get
fatigue on Cumberbatch if I'm being
honest he's a good actor don't get me
wrong but like I'm ready for a break
from what I've seen angels kind of for
Buffy what Big Finish is for Doctor Who
it takes characters and makes them
better I'm to a certain extent keep an
eye on Wesley
because Wesley's character journey over
the course of Angel
I think is one of the best long-term
character arcs in TV is there ever show
that no one could pay you to do a review
for no I am for sale I have my price but
I am for sale I can't think of anything
that if you paid me that I wouldn't do
it because you also have to realize if
you're paying me to watch an entire
season of television chump change so
someone's actually gonna pay me that
yeah sure why not
do you eat hummus if so what do you eat
it with I like it with pita chips and I
prefer garlic hummus I would love to see
Dennis David Tennant and Jodie Whittaker
play off each other as their respective
doctors that could be fun do you prefer
the Bohemian Rhapsody Phil maracas
Oh rock it means a million miles better
than Bohemian Rhapsody and but I'd like
to believe me and Rhapsody fine but ya
know the Rocket Man was so so so so much
better there was a kids TV show used to
watch called hounded that had no
continuity cuz the end of each episode a
device called the reverse button which
reverse the day huh that's one way to do
it
fun fact Tommy was so wanted his
character in the wrong type of floating
card his defense was maybe he vampire
yeah I heard about that 60th anniversary
end of the episode Whitaker says to
Capaldi just so you know I was kind how
he gives a look of confusion then does a
signature smile that'd be nice be second
warranty reminds me remind some of the
shining all work and no play
hey Jack a dull boy do you like the book
i I said I want to try something
subversive a mystery the protagonist
audience want solved that becomes about
the protagonist learning empathy for the
people involved instead I could work
Hambleton movies coming to disney plus
in the third are you doing a review on
it not planning to I would like to see
it I don't have a Disney Plus doesn't
mean I won't see it at some point but
that's it I I haven't carved out time to
do it I got it but have you ever watched
scream queens nope yeah I'm glad doctor
who went off the year through the 90s
cuz they went through a similar thing
the comments did simply through books
horrible things happening to the doctor
and companion Oh God really II never
seen Fullmetal Alchemist friend of mine
recently introduced it to me I have I've
seen the entire run of the original Full
Metal Alchemist I'm have mixed feeling
about it like I do on a lot of animes
look it's good but there's certain
tropes and staples of an anime that I
just don't are we back okay I hope that
was actually down during the time I
thought it was cuz I was swearing
anyways um so full metal alchemist it
was fine but there's certain conventions
of anime I just don't enjoy and full
metal alchemist had pretty much all of
them I started Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and it was immediately
reminded of those same conventions of
anime that I don't like and at least
early on it didn't deviate enough from
the original for me to feel like I
should keep going with it
I've heard a lot of people say it's much
better as been later on goes in his own
direction but I just I didn't like the
original enough to push through
Brotherhood
every general review a spider-man rain
comic where Peter kills Mary Jane
because it was radioactive fluids yes
this is real I'm aware of it I've never
read it but yeah look they did so many
things like that this will be this
characters The Dark Knight Returns it
same thing with super commando it's
called odorous and that was nonsense - I
just want there to be an episode where
the doctor has a hangover and deals with
all the monsters in the laziest way
possible yeah that that'd be fun can we
hear your compile the impression I you
don't want to hear me trying to do
accents cuz like I I like to think I'm
I'm decent at accents but I know in my
heart of hearts that I'm not like the
only impressions I can do are like
stitching Gollum they tried to make the
doctor be half human metaphorical and
hell-bent really fearful more shouting
I've already been in the White House oh
yeah jack meeting The Sixth Doctor
already happened
Oh what did that happening rolls around
in Vera mo ha ha ha have you ever
actually made a video showing yeah I did
video reviews for the last series so
those last three episodes largely
complaining about it cuz Wow Cumberbatch
would be a better master than doctor I'd
be more open to that Richard III can
never know how to pronounce this guy's
last name will be a trick - terrific
doctor I don't think he'd ever do it see
I don't think he would I seem to be
alone on that I've seen a lot of people
thought his name but like I don't know I
don't feel it hmm
I might need to give up trying to trying
to get back to these questions that have
happened would you ever do a video game
review I'm gonna
time to be doing one on the breakroom
next month
like I give me to realize I don't have
current gaming stuff so anything I talk
about is gonna be retro what do you
think about the new Bill and Ted and the
franchise as a whole I think they're fun
movies I did a reaction to the trailer
over in the break room of geeks I hope
it's good
what makes Rocket Man better have heard
mixed reviews up and watched it but make
sure I recommend bet better is the
simple conceit of it is a musical they
use Elton John's own music to tell the
story of his life by turning his life
into a musical it's a very simple
conceit I'm shocked I've never seen it
done before
but it makes all the difference because
ultimately at the end of the day both
Bohemian Rhapsody and Rocket Man are
very standard finding fame and then you
know things start to come apart stories
for rock stars it's the same story
you've seen a million times if you've
ever seen any kind of story like this
but that little difference makes rocket
man feel much fresher than Bohemian
Rhapsody does Clara might be in the 60th
hmm I don't have a question I just want
to say love your hair thank you
let's see when the stream went down now
you should have opened him back up with
hello boys I'm back
is there anything subversive that's
really worked for you depends on what
you think about subversive I mean when
he's not deconstructing Star Wars I
think that Brian Johnson does a really
good a subversion of expectations and
genre tropes in things like knives out
and Brothers Bloom and looper have you
ever seen the 1996 version of 101
Dalmatians Glenn Close as a bombshell in
that movie I've seen bits and pieces I
was a little old for when I
came out sand I never circled back on it
have you ever seen community I did a
couple of episodes then I just I wasn't
hooked I did something else I've always
wanted a multi doctor story where the
future doctor tries to move around the
past doctors adventure without messing
it up that could work Big Finish usually
managed to be more adult without being
with to it is to be exceptions and being
necro neck necromancia that thing I once
told you was the worst episode in Doctor
Who
oh yeah I remember you mentioning that
anyone who taunts you with hell-bent
hasn't seen your worst episode list by
Moffat yeah yeah taunting me with
hell-bent that's something you do at
your own risk just remind you of
terrible comics all-star Batman and
Robin the Boy Wonder wherein all series
seriousness Batman says I love being the
goddamn Batman yeah I know all about the
goddamn Batman and thanks to Linkara I
didn't have to read it myself have you
ever heard the Big Finish bit spin-off
small beginning nope
Jack meeting The Sixth Doctor was in big
finished it was so funny because the
majority that started with Jack
pretending to be the doctor and where
he's outfit huh huh I've watched fleabag
nope
sarcasm incoming I know you don't have
any wack tweets from 10 years ago so if
you don't watch avatar will leak your
second help egg review
when all else fails drink the drink
until the problem is gone next month is
it's tomorrow oh god you're right
what made you decide to make the break
room it was part of a long term goal in
wanting to have the stuff that I put up
in the main channel be a bit more
polished and have a bit more work put
into them and I didn't have the time to
do that with the video release schedule
that I had but I also know I didn't want
to fully abandon the more relaxed
laid-back just sitting from the camera
the camera and ramble thing that I have
been doing for so long but I wanted that
to be moved somewhere that wasn't on a
fixed schedule wasn't like gotta have
these videos out bla bla bla these dates
always it's something that I do just
because I have the time and it's fun and
ideally framing me up to put more time
into the things that go up on this
channel that's the hope and the plan
we'll see how it pans out I thought some
good omens or is it taboo book was good
show was great uh let's see
would you agree that we need to see
Jody's doctors dark side I don't know if
we do I need to see her build like a
proper real connection with a companion
that's what I need I had an idea for a
master in a club giving drunken advice
to people excuse me who wanted to show
the doctor based off is the most stupid
schemes haha see you it was you gotta do
you got help the doctor Linus
stop the universe from blowing up but
then like you you you get on like a
speaker phone and like telling the
universe I am now in control of the
universe and everyone give me all
controller
this book I am so smart
that's Legolas for the record which is a
stupid episode I'm sorry I know it's
beloved and I know that Fourth Doctor
fans like are all like get all choked up
on it but in like there's some
interesting concepts in it but the
master specifically is really dumb in
that it's not good what do you think
about yesterday it was better than today
was and now I'm the movie the thing with
the Beatles I didn't see it have you
heard that Richard Armitage has been
cast as Rassilon and audios he's got the
voice for it yeah
and that could work
Oh angel proper review uh probably not
unless somebody paid me because to do
them properly I'd have to rewatch them
not to mention the fact that passion of
the nerd is really doing the definitive
Buffy review work right now on YouTube
and I can't measure up to that if you
read the original story of the Little
Mermaid it's dark yes I have and yes it
is I'm the gosh-darn doctor do you think
Frank Miller killed some of his other
works because he tried to tie it back to
the Dark Knight Returns no I think Frank
Miller killed his works because he lost
touch with his own talent and sunk into
a very dark place that came out in the
worst way in his written works that's
what I think happened to Frank Miller
how old are you I am 38 sauce almost
suggest Michael Palin would be a good
master huh I don't think I see that I'm
see he's incapable of doing it I'm just
not sure I'd buy it
Anthony head is the doctor I mean yeah
I'm here for it
finally watch the V for Vendetta
watching the nitpick grant I really
didn't think it was supposed to be a
twist that it was V it drags that scene
out so friggin long though I mean my big
issue with that isn't that it's a twist
that just makes it feel insulting my big
issue with that is it lays out playing
these stuff that we could have inferred
so we have this lengthy scene that makes
these other characters look stupid
because if as an audience member you
catch that it's V which is it's almost
impossible not to realize and the cops
don't freaking realize that they look
stupid now and it just conveys
information that was much better left
inferred and it was very well inferred
it's a pointless scene it should not be
in the movie have you seen peaky
blinders I have not I'm sure I'm not
drunk I don't think I don't know why I
stand up that's my bigot indicators if
when I stand up if I feel woozy
what are you saying what do you think
what do you think think what do you
think is the most overrated Doctor Who
episode I don't know most of the ones
that are thought that are considered to
be really good I do tend to like um so
I've got my head I'm not I'm not sure
which doctor would you like to get drunk
with eleventh I mean he'd be fun drunk
twelve would be an angry drunk that's my
favorite doctor but now imagine Helena
Bonham Carter Helen McCray Jodie
Whittaker David Tennant Michelle Gomez
Benedict Cumberbatch I mean Tom
Hiddleston Matt Smith in one room
together okay
so they were in a row
I do not know what is going on tonight
I'd like seriously this has gotten
ridiculous gonna have to wrap it up soon
just for my own sanity I'm so tired of
seeing the Batman Bruce Williams story
in film so ready for Batman Beyond or
Nightwing Batman Beyond I'm down for did
you actually listen to the Good Omens
Quarantine not sure what that is
oh yes not you see the rumors about
Michael Keaton and Flash movie thoughts
I saw the rumors until there's
confirmation I don't have an opinion
like I like it's not like uh some kind
of journalistic integrity you're not a
journalist but like the reef they don't
comment on rumors is I refuse to sink a
bunch of my mental energies into
something that is probably not true I
actually love the master decision in
Legolas because it's so stupid you know
is that it's stupid if you like him for
that resist fair enough he's that
desperate mental for power that he might
just destroy the universe anyway see the
thing is it's not that he it's not that
he's threatening to destroy the
University is that he he literally just
gets on basically a universe why'd PA
system and says give me control of your
plan that's so dumb every time you on
these streams in charge I'll call I
can't help but take it personally really
why Bill Murray for the master 2021 no I
see the wall at the end of that even as
a G oh no Anthony had is fantastic in a
British radio Dickens parody called
bleak expectations where he plays the
hammies villain oh I bet he has a blast
doing that hell-bent is good no it's not
one day I'm surprised no one has done a
story where the master takes over the
doctor's body becomes the doctor
basically Joker in Arkham Knight but
with Doctor Who I'm not a huge fan of
body taking over stories if
got to be completely honest so why
should I run for Prime Minister just
just trust me all right it'll work just
don't get married
turns out the drumming was just a
hangover oh yes the discord I'm sorry
Carolyn I'm sorry I drank too much water
oh my goodness I am very sorry I just
give me a second when I first saw a
friend vendetta I thought for a brief
second that Mark Gatiss was playing work
would remember to drink water before you
go to sleep tonight that was water
ah sorry give me a second
10 would be a mopey drunk yeah
I'm sorry Kira and I feel like a
real-ass now and now I'm seeing that
other people were saying like hey hey
listen I'm sorry okay
let's see so I know there was one that
had been asked earlier there's like a
hold over question so hang on uh there
are various classic books I'd like to
try and read The Hobbit for example but
lost I've never been diagnosed as
dyslexic or anything I've always
struggled to get to grips with novels
would it be cheating if I tried
audiobooks instead no absolutely not
however you take it in it's still the
same story I mean it's not like it's not
like watching the movie and saying you
read the book
cuz that's been changed and trimmed and
Apted but like an audio it's somebody
reading the book no that's not cheating
that's fine and I'll point out if you
don't watch Dominic noble who's a
fantastic youtuber does lost an
adaptation he's talked about being
dyslexic and that a lot of the things
that he reviews from the books that he
reads are the audio version cuz it's
hard for him to to actually read it off
the page a lot of the time so no there's
no shame in that
let's see I've seen very little James
Bond outside of the Daniel Craig films I
wanted to challenge myself to watch at
least one for me just the other Bond
actors what would you recommend see I'm
actually a bad person to ask cuz I'm not
as well-versed in bond to some people so
like for instance I haven't seen on Her
Majesty's Secret Service so I haven't
seen George Lazenby I haven't seen
either of the Timothy Dalton ones but
that having been said if you're gonna do
Connery it should be gold free
and we is Roger Moore I'm actually
partial to for your eyes only personally
lazon B you've only got one option I've
heard The Living Daylights
is the better option for Timothy Dalton
and for Pierce Brosnan Goldeneye easily
those would be the ones I'd recommend if
you want a taste of all of them let's
see some of my favorite film memories
and learning about film as a child we're
staying up late over holidays and being
able to stay up and watch late-night
classics for example Marx Brothers or
Universal Horrors
what were your formative film viewing
experiences well the thing for me was I
spent my childhood watching movies
instead of TV because I didn't have I
think I mentioned this elsewhere but
when I was growing up my mother hated
television not TV shows but she hated
commercials and she ended the news so I
didn't have TV growing up we didn't even
have a rabbit ears not even local
channels I didn't PBS what we had
instead was we had a VCR a whole bunch
of movies a local video store and my
grandmother had cables so she would
occasionally record things off a cable
and send us tapes so my formative
viewing experiences was a lot of movies
growing up I mean that was what I
consumed that I would watch Andrea watch
the same movies over and over again and
that just sort of that that was the the
visual medium language I came to know I
wasn't watching TV I was watching movies
including older movies
like I my childhood dog which was
dachshund its name her name was rose and
I named her after Katharine Hepburn's
character in the African Queen so I had
my share of classic movies growing up
all right coming back to the chat would
you do a review about dr. horrible
probably not if I wasn't paid when did
you get the lava-lamp I love the colors
the love limbs been there since I had
since I moved my filming set up I
haven't remembered to turn it on for
every video but it's been there I would
actually like a body takeover story for
the master but with a random person
except make it a doctor light episodes
slow-paced psychological horror baby on
the movie page I'm getting Batman and
Robin recommended YouTube is being taken
over by BOTS I think the reason you're
getting Batman and Robin recommended is
because Joel Schumacher passed away
recently and so talking about his movies
in general is probably trending as far
as the algorithm is concerned so that's
probably the reason actually I kind of
wanted to touch on that like for me it's
a shame that people seem to associate
Joel Schumacher's name with Batman Robin
because I think of him as the guy who
directed Lost Boys and phone booth and
falling down you know he the guy made
legitimately good movies so do you think
other Doctor Who story should be adapted
to stage I don't know I'm not sure which
which ones would even make that
translation I really like reading the
physical book with the audio read by
someone good once in a while is that
weird no I don't think so don't make
sense to me the outro for the strangers
reminds me of that audiobook the guy in
the crane from series 11
of doctor who had okay not even sure
what you mean by that
loose Mahoney who played old Billy and
blink passed away this week oh that's a
shame
someone else just essentially has a
similar question to my favorite Bond
films I love for your eyes only I feel
like that what doesn't come up in
conversation a lot but from the Roger
Moore ones I've seen it's the least
campy excuse me also Thank You Thomas I
appreciate that a lot
classic who are modern who depends on
what you're after like I came into this
on modern who I'm gonna re-watch modern
he'll a lot more but there are things
about classic food that I do appreciate
like its ability to take a slower pace
and to take more time and to have the
doctor have to work harder to figure
something out because there's the time
for him to do that so it's not just
waving the sonic screwdriver at
everything there's a lot of things that
I appreciate about classic who but
ultimately if I'm gonna sit down and
watch Doctor Who for fun it's gonna be
modern I'm also partial to for your eyes
only think it's probably Roger Moore's
best performance even though my favorite
from his eras The Spy Who Loved me if
you were Time Lord and we are the
council does that mean you would be
known as the administrator not a very
intimidating title is it it sounds very
bureaucratic when when is the novel
coming out into your traditional it's
good it's got to be self-published I've
accepted that at this point and I don't
know I'm really trying to get it knuckle
down to have it out this year I'm not
gonna make promises cuz I'm had to I'm
having a really hard time finding the
time to work on the edit I will say
mention the Good Omens quarantine a few
streams banks basically ten and gene
discussing the lockdown as Crowley and a
zero felt no I hadn't seen that I have
seen some episodes of staged that those
two did those are a lot of fun how do I
delete the entire portion of the
internet that still Randy about the
sequel trilogy of Star Wars
you can't just don't go to that part of
the internet like I didn't even know
people are still yelling about that cuz
I don't go there
I think unicorn the wasps would be a
perfect story to adaptive stage that was
that what would adapt pretty smoothly
do you watch my little pony I'm assuming
you mean the new one friendship is magic
no I don't the most underrated episode
of Doctor Who includes the face of evil
the doctor's wife under the lake before
the flood return of doctor Mysterio and
can you hear me
I'll agree with those last two I don't
feel like doctor's wife is underrated I
feel like that's a pretty well liked
episode face of evil haven't seen yet if
doctor who had to go away forever how
would you end it
I wouldn't you do not even if the show
for some reason had to end and could
never start up again
you still don't put a definitive end
you end with the doctor or whatever
doctor going off to continue to have
more adventures and we just don't see
them favorite first story for me it has
to be the Aztecs see I recently watched
that there's gonna be a video going up
on the breakroom about that for me it's
gonna be Dalek invasion of Earth what's
your favorite classical episode my mine
is lakopolous you know what I made fun
of earlier in the stream in the city of
death what was up with certein using her
sonic to untie rope I mean I get if she
was shown to be like a lazy character
but she isn't I don't know the sonic
gets the here's the thing I don't have
them I don't have a problem with a sonic
having a bajillion functions
I do think narrative League it gets
overused I've discovered the lingo
dimension called the Dalek extermination
earth genuinely funny it's always nice
to see slight parodies of the Doctor Who
nice forgot to say this as well if they
want to bring Donna back they could do
it at a point in their timeline when she
was traveling with Tennant oh that's
true that would work
how are you watching staged I don't need
to sleep I need answers there were
episodes up on YouTube
possibly not legally they might be down
now but that's that's where I was saying
it how do you think Werner Herzog would
direct a season of Doctor Who
chaotically a Doctor Who episode that I
think was adapted into a stage play was
midnight that would actually be really
difficult for for some of those dialogue
bits but as far as staging and it's a
bottle episode yeah that would work
what's your favorite Broadway musical
next to normal trauma Pertwee you played
Alfred and Gotham she'll play the third
doctor in the 60th anniversary special
see I don't want Shawn to play his
father's doctor I actually would like
him to play the
but I'd like him to play his own doctor
have you watched snowpiercer TV series I
have not I saw the movie
but I haven't seen the show ever watch
mst3k a few back in the day more
important how to bring wolf back for the
60th that I'm in favor of the thing I
like about angley's performance in
legatos is how still his face is like he
hasn't worked out how to operate the
muscles yet lakopolous is good i it has
its flaws but it's still good I'm biased
as it was my first clásico episode and
sees any teams in my favorite classic
whose season fare biases exists start a
broad Church recently only one episode
in it's already a ohh
their Doctor Who fest yeah a little bit
did you watch the new Red Dwarf
I haven't yet it's supposed to be
hitting brick box a tail end of July so
I'll get to see it then one thing took
me out of the Aztecs was Ian a teacher
Teyana Aztec warriors the 60s yeah but
wasn't his backstory that he was a that
he was a veteran Mike isn't that part of
his background or did I imagine that oh
I think it might need to wrap this up
soon don't really like lakopolous but I
I haven't seen lakopolous play I do
really like a strip alpha kashkaval was
great I I do agree with that that is a
very good episode hmm boy that should be
clue right there okay oh so yeah I'm
gonna wrap it up I think thank you
everybody for tuning in I'm sorry it was
kind of grouchy I'm sorry for all the
technical hiccups this time let's bring
Frobisher for the 60th haha
or at least reference him that'd be nice
it's been a long day yeah it has Karen
yes it has we all have to admit that
city of death had the best cameo in
Doctor Who ever
it was a good one we all know the best
master is the standing from the movie so
yeah I am gonna wrap it up I hope
everybody has has a good night stay safe
stay well be kind and just remember that
you are the counsel I just run the
meetings at least for as long as the
drinks hold out and also remember that
you're beautiful you're valid you are
loved
you're the counsel I'm just running the
meetings have a good night